I don’t even like using the word
urn to be quite honest,
it just sounds a bit morbid.
This is a piece of my grandmother
that I keep with me all the time.
Over the past decade or so, ashes
creations have started to appear.
I look at it and I just remember
all the good times we had.
In Classical Greece and Rome,
you had both burial and
cremation practices taking place.
Of course in other parts
of the world, traditional aspects
in Buddhism - again cremation.
Of course the Jews, never cremation,
burial normative. Islam, burial.
But of course, long before this
India was a cremation culture.
And once Christianity became
established in the UK...
...and that continued really
until the mid-19th Century
when, with industrialisation and
the rise of big towns, big cities,
church yards got full fast.
The miasmas, the gases that
were rising from putrefied bodies
were considered to be very unhealthy.
The Cremation Society was founded
in 1874 by Sir Henry Thompson
who was a celebrated surgeon.
And he was joined by a number
of free thinkers who were drawn
from the realms of medicine,
science and the arts.
Price was really a very
flamboyant character.
A Welsh nationalist, and
self-appointed Archdruid of Wales.
Price was arrested, and sent
to trial at Cardiff assizes
where Judge Stephen ruled
that cremation was not illegal,
providing it didn’t cause
any public nuisance.
So in 1902...
So by the time we get
into the 1940s and 50s,
something really interesting
was happening.
You were having women dying
who no longer had a husband's
grave that they had to go into.
So the issue of choice that cremation
was now, as it were, on the cards
and a possibility, and so about
the middle of the 1960s,
that Britain flips from being burial
majority to cremation majority.
It's really extraordinary that the
percentage of deaths that resulted
in cremation in 1939 stood at 3.5%.
And now of course the cremation rate
in the UK stands at nearly 80%.
From something like the mid-1970s,
the British started doing something
which many people on the continent
to this day find weird.
They started taking cremated remains
away from the crematorium
and doing their own thing with them.
Just seems weird
to call it an urn to me.
I like to think of it
as a piece of art
that just happens to have
my mum and dad inside it.
This is a piece of my grandmother,
my memorial jewellery
that I keep with me all the time.
All ashes creations are about
keeping our loved ones close.
Any memorial
is for the people left behind.
It's never for the person,
it's for us to carry on
with that memorial.
It's allowed the dead to become
part of the furniture of our life.
My ashes creation is a tattoo
and in it includes the ashes
of my late partner who passed
away two and a half years ago.
A small number of people choose
to have ashes mixed into tattoo ink.
He was my friend
and I also got a tattoo.
And their bodies are literally
mingled together.
As chair of The Cremation Society, I
will naturally choose to be cremated.
I think my daughter will have me
incorporated into a vinyl record
because I love music,
maybe something by the Beastie Boys.
I do not belong
to the tattoo generation.
I don’t think there's enough room
in there to fit me in with them.